Recall that the power in a computing
system has, roughly speaking, two parts.
The first is constant power, which is
what you pay just to keep the system on.
The other part is dynamic power.
That's what you pay above and
beyond constant power while
the program is running.
Let's take a quick look at some of
the basic circuits 101 drivers underlie
dynamic power.
Imagine a simple logic gate,
taken out of a larger circuit.
This gate has a certain
amount of physical energy.
It is both right and natural to
represent that energy by analogy
to a snifter of mighty fine
Atlanta-based beverage.
Quick extra credit if you
can name this brewery.
Now suppose a gate input changes.
Then the energy dissipates and also,
quite naturally, has to be refilled.
But differently when the circuit
switches there will be some energy loss.
This energy loss then
has to be restored.
Let's first ask how
much energy that is and
then ask how frequently
this switching happens.
Let's see how to compute dynamic power.
Start with the amount of energy consumed
by this gate during a state change.
In electrical engineering terms
C is the gate's capacitance.
Capacitance is a function of
the material properties and
geometry of the gate.
V is the supply voltage.
Supply voltage is part
of a circuit design.
it can, for some circuits,
be tuned over some range.
More importantly is how V
enters into the equation.
It enters as the square.
Now for our class, it's not too
important to understand exactly where
this relationship comes from.
But do remember that the product
CV squared quantifies energy.
So how often does switching happen?
Well there are two factors.
The first is the frequency or
clock rate of the circuit.
It has units of cycles per unit time.
The clock rate determines the maximum
number of times that the circuit can
switch or change states per unit time.
Now the gate doesn't necessarily
switch on every cycle.
Depending on what
the computation is doing,
the switches might happen
only once ever few cycles.
That brings us to the second factor,
which is the activity factor.
It's the number of switches per cycle.
If you think about how a clock works,
it has a maximum value of one.
In general, it will depend on
what the computation is doing.
Taken together, these parameters tell
us how to compute dynamic power.
It's basically the energy per gate, or
CV squared,
times the switching frequency.
Which is a times F.
This formula is sometimes called
the Dynamic Power Equation.
Before moving on, let me give you
one more quick fact about it.
The clock rate, F and
the supply voltage,
V usually need to be kept in
proportion to one another.
That is, suppose you've cut F in half.
Then you also need to cut V in half.
Increases are the same.
Suppose you increase F by two.
Then you also need to double V.
So why do F and
V need to change together?
The short story is that it has to do
with maintaining the stability and
reliability of the circuit.
In particular, its Its reliability in
the presence of environmental noise.
Okay, now's a good time to pause and
see if you can understand what this
this formula implies can be done if you
want to increase performance
while reducing power.